hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday October 31st 2016 what's going on
how are ya
it's Halloween everybody happy Halloween
oh happy Hall of [ __ ] ween happy
Allah [ __ ] weed dah dah dah you're a
[ __ ] teen it's you're too [ __ ] old
for candy what's the cutoff what's the
cutoff tonight when the kids come well
you just want to be with some of them
just be like dude you're too [ __ ] old
Cleo get out of here I'll feed you in a
minute
go on I'm telling you my cutoff is
somewhere around like [ __ ] 12 you
know even around 10 they just start
saying little wiseass [ __ ] [ __ ]
things you know that's the hardest thing
about being an adult around a kid is
they think they're so [ __ ] smart and
it's just like douche I was I was your
age I've been 10 I've been 12 okay then
I've been 20 30 40 almost up to 50
you're right you dumb [ __ ] do you think
I've you think I don't know what you
doing do you think you're playing with
my mind man I mean just we just want to
say to you remember that you know
everybody's got to have that do you ever
have that [ __ ] adult that just
[ __ ] you know just when your parents
weren't looking just looked at you and
just told you to shut the [ __ ] up it
probably doesn't happen nowadays because
of all the smart phones and everybody's
got a video camera and the kid blogs
about it next thing you know you get
arrested for a writer I don't know what
I don't know what Cleo get out of here
go on go on
you know but back then I mean that's the
kind of [ __ ] you could do I remember we
were talking in church me and my brother
and this dude [ __ ] turn around he
goes hey you shut up you said that
because we shut up you know it's just
one of those things you know and my
mother and I looked at my mother and she
[ __ ] put her eyebrows up like but
yeah well shut the [ __ ] up
that doesn't happen nowadays a pair oh
my you don't talk you know abuse no your
kid needs to shut the [ __ ] up so what
what our teeth is this etch that [ __ ]
our where they just stop being cute you
know they just stop being cute and they
get [ __ ] annoying and then it it goes
over the hill where it just becomes like
you know they're coming up to you thing
and they got the shitty and Grinch smirk
on their face I'm telling you this
[ __ ] year this [ __ ] year some kid
comes up with a smirk on his face I go
I'm not giving you any candy cuz that
look on your face this is what I want to
say but you can't because of that look
on your face and if you do anything to
my mailbox or anything like that I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you
alright you [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't even
how to drive yet get the [ __ ] out of
here alright but you can't say you know
you can't not not today's America not
today well you know what Trump's gonna
bring that back I've had such a bad
experience like all my life oh my laughs
I don't know it was uh I've been waiting
for like I couldn't wait to have a
[ __ ] house that kids came by to go
trick-or-treating I mean I moved out and
now the first time I live like in the up
the Attic of a [ __ ] old house that
they turned into an apartment it was
[ __ ] hilarious and you had to like
walk down the center of the apartment so
you hid head wouldn't hit either side of
the [ __ ] roof
and I told you guys this right I didn't
have a bed I slept in a sleeping bag and
I would sleep right by the window
because I didn't we didn't have any AC
and then one night there was like some
torrential downpour I was sitting there
dream and I was on a boat or something
some about water and I woke up just
soaking wet vidios funy ended up
catching a cold and like the next day it
was like July it was like 89 degrees out
or something and I had a cold like it
was [ __ ] November
oh god that [ __ ] sucked then I moved
back in with my parents got my [ __ ]
together [ __ ] finally graduated
[ __ ] college and then when I moved
out I ended up going to New York City
and people don't go trick-or-treating in
New York City they have places where
they go we're all the [ __ ] candy is
and they make sure there's no [ __ ]
weirdos there and then when I finally
moved out to LA I don't know people
still didn't come to my first apartment
is when I got my house you know five
years ago there was just like all right
now they're gonna be coming and I was
[ __ ] loaded for bear and I had you I
did the bid on I had the full-size candy
bars Jesus Christ Cleo you're driving me
nuts get over there and lay down there's
no way to be mad at a dog for longer
than four frustrated more than three
seconds Cleo can you please lay down hey
buddy
lay down down go on lay down
there you go and the follow through
thank you I already can tell she's not
gonna sit there cuz she's laying down
but she has her ears up and she's just
staring at me you know what it is I had
to get up early to do this [ __ ]
podcast cuz I got a bunch of [ __ ] that I
need to do so anyways people finally
started coming in the [ __ ] house and
that's what I found you know soon as the
Sun Goes Down the first I know we always
talk about this but you gotta admit it's
true the first like hour and a half it's
the cutest [ __ ] kids you've ever seen
the parents are great you know it's just
like a great it's just I don't know it's
[ __ ] awesome the kids are adorable
and then somewhere around I don't know
between seven and eight it starts
switching over and there's just nothing
but [ __ ] like after like a quarter to
nine I mean just everybody you see it's
gonna be a bunch of [ __ ] and you know
something we rent in this [ __ ] house
it's got this crazy driveway I don't
think anybody's gonna come up here but
next year I promise you guys I have to
[ __ ] I want to open a door and be
like and you guys you're too old you're
too old looking
go buy some candy get the [ __ ] out of
here but then you gotta worry they're
gonna [ __ ] up your house even if they
don't do it that night they're gonna do
it another night
just come on man you guys are too old
maybe I'll just lie and be like guys
sorry I'm out of candy no taller you 5-1
yeah I'm out of candy what do you got
yeah there's before you're not 411 [ __ ]
out of here you're five foot one beat it
oh you're you know what you do is is
what's the worst kind of [ __ ] candy
it's just a shitty old lady kind of
candy that's what you do you know the
[ __ ] fruit in the middle of it like
it real fruit oh my god I don't know
about you guys I don't know what
grandmother's are like nowadays when I
was a kid man my grandma my grandparents
had the worst [ __ ] candy at least one
of them did and then like the [ __ ] I had
a paper route and then there was like a
bunch of old biddies and [ __ ] that you
know coupled I never got married and
[ __ ] or that dad [ __ ] they're dead
the [ __ ] husband died and they'd
always have like this little candy I
have a piece of candy right and I'd go
to bite it - oh God I didn't know what
the [ __ ] it was it was just it was just
horrible just it just you know it was
like did they put you a perfume in the
middle of this [ __ ] I'm sorry it was for
it was I'm just saying it was disgusting
alright so anyways I'm actually going to
a Halloween party tonight I was gonna
make some pumpkin bread for the host
right I was like the party and Nia's
going like I was like god man I got so
much [ __ ] to do when I go and I got to
make that pumpkin bread and then she
just goes like well why don't you just
like not do that we'll just you know
we'll go get a bottle of champagne she
always does that she always gives you
make your life so [ __ ] hard it's like
it's pumpkin bread it's not that it's
just like [ __ ] it's gonna take me
like you know ten minutes to put it
together and then throw it in the
[ __ ] oven for an hour it's just a
pain in the ass to do it she why don't
we just do this like what the [ __ ] you
just be another [ __ ] showing up with
a bottle of wine as opposed to showing
up with pumpkin bread the [ __ ] is you
know I don't know
now sometimes four sometimes NRO
sometimes we don't [ __ ] we just don't
see that I'd like I want to make my own
steamed dumpling she goes I just buy him
a Trader Joe's you know those are those
are the times you know what I mean those
are times we just want to kind of smile
and nod just slowly back towards the
front door get in the car and just never
come back again
yeah in other words you'd lie to
yourself that that's what you're gonna
do for the next 20 minutes as you drive
around you know talking to yourself it
[ __ ] red lights you look over there's
some beautiful woman half your aides go
and look at that crazy bald old guy and
you just sit there you gotta be like wow
I'm the crazy bald old guy and then you
give you go back home and then that's it
that's not works but every once in a
while not actually once a while more
people than not can commit to that they
can back their way out the front door
and they can go through with it
they take it all the way to the divorce
you know they go out they get themselves
a toupee you know they paint an orange
they get a red tie they run for office
they start people up at truckstops
this election is so [ __ ] up that it's
got really quiet down after the last
[ __ ] debate if that's what the [ __ ]
you want to call it my big thing this
year is I want to know it's just [ __ ]
lose-lose
it's [ __ ] lose-lose at the thing and
you know something as much as I've been
sitting here [ __ ] saying you know
Trump's a [ __ ] racist and bla bla bla
bla bla it's just like well you know the
Clintons are from Arkansas so you know I
think that to [ __ ] lighten down there
either
you know well you know I know I'm just
[ __ ] being stereotypical here but
give me a break Oh bill and [ __ ] a
Hillary they grew up in Arkansas in like
the 50s you might want to go back and
look at some of those [ __ ] racist
you know the
racist people screaming at black people
kids going to school for the first time
you might want to try to pick her head
out or something like that give me a
[ __ ] break
you're from Arkansas I love that [ __ ]
word just because you're a Democrat that
just means that you know that you're not
homophobic you're not racist story I
have AB I wear blue
I just don't [ __ ] or that if you're a
Republican then that automatically means
that you you know you want to bury
babies in the backyard you know unless
they're [ __ ] blue-eyed white babies
you know what I mean like that whole
[ __ ] you knowing that the
corporations and all that they're all
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know I know that cuz
I'm a [ __ ] to and I'm somewhere in the
middle I like to think I definitely lean
more [ __ ] left but I'm also
contrarian and now I live out here in
Hollywood and I just can't [ __ ] deal
with these people out here and that it's
it's driving me I don't think it's
driving me to the right it's it's
driving me to say things on the right
just to [ __ ] with these people like I
love trash and Hillary out here it's one
of my favorite [ __ ] things to do you
know I had last night I was [ __ ]
around the stage and I was talking about
that I'm talking about you know well
Hillary's from [ __ ] Arkansas
everybody and they all kind of laughed I
go you know those those [ __ ] flyover
states that you guys all [ __ ] on out
here you know and you know of course it
gets [ __ ] wrong I don't whatever you
know what the big thing isn't it's on
this ballot is wherever the [ __ ] you
live more important than one of that
orange headed [ __ ] racist [ __ ] or
that devil woman with her [ __ ] issues
right she lived in Arkansas in the 1950s
Jesus Christ
write me a [ __ ] break B or you know
what the biggest [ __ ] thing is Sartre
lose my train of thought here is those
is all the props the state propositions
you know this is what pisses me off so I
go to this website to try to figure out
California 17 ballot measure
propositions explained all right and all
they do it they sort of explain the
thing but what they don't have what I
cannot find is all the [ __ ] that is
attached to each one of these
propositions like
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] up and I do not
understand why this is never addressed
why on all these propositions like no
means yes yes means no and then there's
a little bit of maybe in there and then
if you vote for the [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
some other measure saying that you know
yeah it's ok you [ __ ] stick a baby in
a snowbank for [ __ ] you know 13 hours
until it freezes to death or whatever oh
how [ __ ] long would look it would
take you know I just I can't find
anything that says all this [ __ ] that's
attached to it why can't the [ __ ]
ballot just be [ __ ] the proposition
just be written clearly so regular
people understand it yes means yes no
means no and there's nothing else to
attach to it you know like they'll say
all right there we go Proposition 51
allows the sales of nine billion in
bonds to pay for four new kindergarten
to 12th grade in Community College
facilities the basics roughly six
million students attend Kate you know
the [ __ ] is Proposition 51 wants to
address the needs by allowing the sale
of nine billion in general obligation
bonds to pay for buildings and
modernizing k12 and community college
it's the first school bond measure on
the state ballots since 2006 it's
unusual because it's sponsored by the
building industry okay right there the
fact that it's sponsored by the building
industry means they're gonna charge us
up the [ __ ] ass and in the end even
though they get 9 billion they're gonna
come in with the [ __ ] tab of about 15
billion and then they can be like well
we already started so guess we gonna
physically move through Bluto typically
the Legislature would be the path for
getting this kind of proposition on the
ballot but it hasn't been able to do so
in recent years yeah the fact that the
building industry wants to do it you
already know this is crooked as [ __ ]
what you're voting on about 7 billion
nearly a seedling of this [ __ ] 7 billion
would be allocated to the k-12 thing and
and what another 2 billion we depleted
for the Community College I got to read
all of this [ __ ]
supporters include developers builders
school board officials and business
groups I'd only get any of those people
all right
supporters say all right a supporters
say many of our schools need repairs and
upgrades to make them safe for our
children that's very vague proposition
51 will improve education overall and
help expand Spacek community colleges so
more students can attend
opponents say prop 54 would add to the
state debt which is already more than
four hundred billion how the [ __ ] is
California four and a billion of debt
bond measures should be passed locally
giving communities control of how the
money is spent and Jesus I mean do you
feel any closer all right so there's one
comment close the border eliminate
anchor babies citizenship and
reinstitute and reinstitute of all
provisions of prop Proposition 187 let's
talk about building more schools sorry I
used to always vote YES on these now
Sacramento has changed my vote I always
vote no on school bonds quid pro quo
baby
what does quid pro quo mean where the
[ __ ] is it quid pro quo meaning and I
love that everybody else is as dumb as
me a favor or advantage granted or
expected in return for something that
doesn't get me any close to
understanding it quid pro quo jesus
[ __ ] christ what what am I in law and
order here quid pro quo means in
exchange in exchange of goods goods or
services where one transfer is
contingent upon the other English
speakers often is this tit for tat yeah
jesus [ __ ] christ english speakers
often use the term to mean a favor for a
favor
phrases with similar meanings would
include give-and-take tit for tat and
you scratch my back I'll scratch yours
quid pro quo I guess that's the [ __ ]
snooty way of saying that [ __ ] let's go
back to close the borders here so I can
try to figure out what his [ __ ] point
is
oh I get it close the [ __ ] borders
and then I'll [ __ ] then I'll give
money to the side I see what the guys
saying I don't know if it's right or not
all right [ __ ] politics all right you
know what I try I [ __ ] tried old
freckles has not flipped out about
technology and I figured out how to
watch the NHL on my phone because
somebody in the room knew how to do it
and they walked me through it and at one
point I started to get upset because I
go it's not going on he goes what I mean
it's not going that's supposed to go on
now and I go and then I started get me I
go why would it go what why would it go
Don it's me if I'm [ __ ] done in just
brought it down don't bring it down
bring it down you know what I mean like
you ever see somebody like revving up
the engine ready to do a Burnout then I
brought it all the way down you know
before the tires stopped moving and I
realized that was not the tires I was
actually burning out the clutch it's one
of the most disgusting things you'll
ever see is somebody trying to do a
[ __ ] burnout and I don't know what
happens I still don't quite understand
I've never done one I just never wanted
to beat the [ __ ] out of my car I
basically get it with a stick shift I
don't know how you do it with an
automatic I've watched [ __ ] the
videos but it's basically you get your
our premiums up you let the clutch out
and then you stomp on the [ __ ] brake
see your tires are already [ __ ] going
but somehow if you [ __ ] that up you let
the clutch out and you're revving the
engine and your tires aren't [ __ ]
moving and you burn out your clutch and
it's it's the I don't know what that
smells like but the smoke is
evil-looking alright let's move on here
oh did anybody watch the Patriots game
yesterday Cleo get over there and lay
down every always and about you go on go
lay down go lay down
I can't even [ __ ] begin to tell you
how much I enjoyed that's the the fact
that the [ __ ] Patriots beat the bills
yesterday I didn't say this because I
take up beforehand because I take a nod
I get what Bill Belichick does in his
press conferences what he's like I'm not
gonna say anything negative about
anybody I'm not gonna give you any
advantages because you [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
in the media are gonna
take this and give bulletin board
material for the other team I got to
tell you watching the [ __ ] Buffalo
Bills when we played them we had a third
string quarterback with a broken [ __ ]
hand or whatever the [ __ ] was wrong with
them how they got in his face before the
game was such a bush-league [ __ ] move
to the point like I've always liked
Buffalo I might be done with that
franchise like I used to give a [ __ ] I
you know they lost four in a row now I'm
just like you know what [ __ ] them you
know it's like you're that insecure that
you're not gonna win the [ __ ] game
that you gotta try to pull some [ __ ]
like that and now it's just like that
then I was just thinking you're like you
know what two great things happen we
lost so now we don't the deal with the
pressure of the [ __ ] undefeated
season all of the extra media hype that
comes if New England's going undefeated
if you [ __ ] Indianapolis with old
[ __ ] uh what would have [ __ ] his
name there Peyton Manning you can be all
the way to 13 and Oh nobody say nothing
man right so you took that away and then
also I'm like the Patriots are gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] team
the next time because of that [ __ ]
because I know in house they must have
talked about it and there you go you get
41 [ __ ] points whatever the [ __ ] we
scored against you haven't said all that
I'd like to say a lot of positive things
like Tyrod Taylor is like impossible to
[ __ ] tackle I know the Bills had a
bunch of [ __ ] injuries and I'd make
those excuses but they don't give a [ __ ]
those [ __ ] animals they don't give a
[ __ ] they were talking all kinds of
trash to a third string quarterback like
they were coming out on the field
getting ready to lose another [ __ ]
Super Bowl I love that you [ __ ]
ringless I love that you're four and
three hey Buffalo we're on our way to
the playoffs see you next year fuckos
wow I enjoyed that I really [ __ ]
enjoyed that
you know [ __ ] Rex Ryan told them to
do it - oh god I've been waiting to go
off on this you [ __ ] get out there
and you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz we're the best [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] AFC [ __ ] East yeah go
have another [ __ ] hero your tub of
[ __ ] you want to talk about cheating
you know we let a little air out of the
ball he got [ __ ] that's dead stomach
gastric surgery he's not fees a fat [ __ ]
he cheated letting air out of the ball
he had a [ __ ] choke up three quarters
of his stomach so he could actually see
his dick every once in a while ah sorry
sorry anyways yeah I and I got to tell
you something else the [ __ ] watching
this World Series I've gone back and
forth back and forth and back and forth
about who the [ __ ] I'm rooting for I
mean how do you do it one team's waiting
[ __ ] 70 not quite 70 years right 68
years said what it is yeah 68 years the
other team hasn't even been to the
[ __ ] World Series in 71 years and I
know you guys think of Bill you're a
[ __ ] Red Sox fan how can we not for
the Cubs
I was totally for the Cubs until I saw
the 34:30 on [ __ ] Bartman and when I
watched it all of their hey let's play
to you no way you know where the lovable
[ __ ] losers we always show up we just
root for them all of that went out the
window the way that they [ __ ] what do
what they did to that kid I just looked
at that [ __ ] going like that's exactly
what would have happened that if someone
in Boston did that New York Philly
Cleveland these Cubs fans for all their
[ __ ] you know mr. Smith goes to watch
Washington [ __ ] apple pie and
Chevrolet way that they did they're just
like us they're [ __ ] animals I'm not
saying they're as bad as Bills fans all
that [ __ ] franchise those [ __ ]
the time I was wearing a Patriots hat it
was the Bills Jets I was rooting for the
bills I'm taking a piss in the bathroom
and somebody pushed me from behind while
I was taking the piss what kind of a
[ __ ] coward
maybe there's a reason the last four in
a [ __ ] row you know I used to think
it was because of my lady he was just
too nice to win a [ __ ] Super Bowl and
he went up against Jimmy Johnson let's
get him some hookers and a Corvette
right and [ __ ] whatever that other
guy's name is Jerry Jones
with his Real Housewife [ __ ] looking
face good lord that guy always looks
like you know he got like first-degree
burns on his face or maybe like slightly
like into the second degrees but he was
like all right he refused medical
treatment and he just put some salve on
his face I know I'm going hard this week
I don't know why I have no idea why I'll
tell you why you know why cuz last night
I wanted to [ __ ] come home and do my
goddamn podcast but my wife you know
wanted to watch a scary movie so I said
okay let's watch it so we started
watching that but Duke Duke Duke
whatever the [ __ ] that thing is and I
got about like I got about 40 minutes
into that movie it's like honey I don't
want to watch the rest of this all right
I hate watching scary movies because I
buy in I [ __ ] buy in and I'm just
like I don't want to watch this thing
terrorizing this woman in the kid for
the next [ __ ] 90 goddamn minutes
because I know neither one of them's
gonna die and I know eventually they're
gonna figure out how to put Paducah Duke
back into the [ __ ] thing and then
they're gonna do something with the book
that lets me know that there's gonna be
another one because they're always you
know [ __ ] horror movies can never
just [ __ ] end you don't I mean every
one of them they got to get greedy like
Friday the 13th part [ __ ] 97 you know
what I mean Nightmare on Elm Street you
know they did like 20 of those
Hellraiser 15 Evil Dead part 6 they just
want to keep [ __ ] going and I don't
know I just don't like [ __ ] sitting
there being have an anxiety you know and
with each scene they're gradually gonna
ramp it up the first time it's just a
little bit of knocking and then there's
a shadow and then you know I was just
like this thinks gonna I got a bad
feeling this thing's gonna kill the dog
and I don't want to [ __ ] see that
all right there any foreshadowed in the
book that that's what's gonna happen you
know they kind of showed you basically
with the pop-up book [ __ ] off you think
I'm ruining this it's this is like
paint-by-numbers every [ __ ] one of
them I getting upset because I just hate
so I was like I don't wanna watch the
rest of this so she ends up shutting it
off and then
she's like [ __ ] pissed she's like
[ __ ] pissed at me and it's just like
I like what's world my wife doesn't give
a [ __ ] about Westworld I'm still on
Episode two cuz every night I want to
[ __ ] watch it she's like me I want to
watch The Real Housewives of [ __ ] st.
Louis so whatever the [ __ ] it is so
anyways let me get back to the Cubs
thing so right out of the gate not only
is the country it seems for the for the
Chicago Cubs it's kind of having this
vibe of this foregone conclusion that
they're kind of gonna win this thing so
I have family or I had family back in
the day out in Ohio my grandmother
worked for the Cleveland press you know
and way back in the day I had family you
know I just had family about there right
and so growing up I kind of was you know
I was always a Red Sox fan but you know
I kind of you know through my relatives
also kind of rooted for the Indians you
know what I mean like I didn't I didn't
mind the Indians even though they were
in our division way back in the day that
in the Tigers you know what I mean just
because of relatives cousins and all
that [ __ ] so I was just like you know I
kind of like the [ __ ] Indians any now
that's the Bartman [ __ ] like the level
that they took that tooth that's exactly
what would happen in Philly and all this
[ __ ] if it happened out in LA
that poor kid what it got killed you
don't even you know San Diego or
Sacramento a Fresno or one of these
[ __ ] lunatic [ __ ] cities out here
where they take sports Oakland way too
seriously
San Francisco you know so maybe just
kind of [ __ ] sort of pull back and
then also it's like I know what I'm kind
of over these [ __ ] cities that have
two professional teams in one sport it's
like Chicago won a World Series they won
it in 2005 and that whole [ __ ] thing
where it's like well that was just that
was for the south side of the city so
what you need another one for the north
side
[ __ ] the White Sox and the Cubs if she
one of them wins just [ __ ] jump on a
subway or walk three blocks downtown or
uptown and join the [ __ ] parade
already same thing with the Yankees and
the Mets the Lakers and the Clippers and
everything in [ __ ] New York Giants
Jets Yankees Mets [ __ ] Rangers
Islanders Knicks and nets just [ __ ] off
with that [ __ ] already it's a New York
team if they win by your championship
hat and go down there and just be happy
that especially New York that you're so
[ __ ] filthy stinking [ __ ] rich
that you can have eight teams or
everybody else is doing bat of doing
backflips if they just have one in every
sport you know I know isn't amazing that
New York has all those [ __ ] teams and
they don't win that much you think that
Jesus Christ you got eight eight at-bats
every [ __ ] year the [ __ ] Yankees I
swear to God are like the sugar daddy of
New York City you know what I mean the
Giants are the favorite son and
everybody else is getting read written
out of the will
that's basically how it works with the
sports in New York do you know what New
York should get three teams in every
[ __ ] City maybe they could [ __ ] do
something other than the yankees and the
giants I have totally [ __ ] respect
for them but Jesus Christ the [ __ ]
Knicks should combine with the nets you
know make like a [ __ ] dream team of
those two [ __ ] shows same thing with the
Rangers in the Islanders you know I
don't know the Jets and the Mets I don't
know what they should do they should
both retire and they should start
playing badminton
oh Jesus Bell um so anyway so I'm really
[ __ ] sitting there and um I'm loving
seeing Terry Francona killing it and it
gets all the way up to three games to
one all right and I don't know something
happened okay my Cleveland friends
comedians one of them in particular just
starts he's just talking all this [ __ ]
and blah blah blah blah blah and he
starts to we got we won the basketball
now we're gonna win the baseball you
know you watch we're going on a [ __ ]
run you
with no [ __ ] respect and he's talking
to a fan for Boston you know I mean it's
just like oh you gonna win two in one
[ __ ] year yeah we did that we did
that a couple of times and then we won
every [ __ ] we did all of this others
I'm not [ __ ] throwing that in your
face I'm always the guy going like a
door now he'll say no no I never believe
we're gonna do it until we do it and
then we do then I'm [ __ ] psyched and
you go back to my podcast I wasn't even
a [ __ ] when when we beat Seattle so
these guys are acting like such [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you don't I mean oh we got LeBron we're
gonna [ __ ] do it again this year
oh the Bron oh you mean the guy that you
guys all burned his jersey and you're
all done with virzi called that one Oh
Paul virzi called that one Paul virzi
[ __ ] when he was in Miami and these
Cleveland fans were saying [ __ ] that guy
blah blah blah blah
first he said to him you guys are all
gonna be sucking his dick when he comes
back to town and they were like no way
that's never gonna happen well it's
happening that whole cities on their
[ __ ] knees so anyways so at some
point after they went up three games to
one I went back to the Cubs the reality
is is I don't give a [ __ ] who wins his
[ __ ] thing cuz it's gonna be great
for one city it's gonna be devastating
for the other city obviously but so
here's the deal this is what's at stake
with this World Series if the Cubs win
the Indians become the Cubs they become
the ones that have gone the [ __ ]
longest alright so they can't [ __ ]
loose all right if Cleveland wins all
right not only the Cubs still the Cubs
as far as my quick research research
showed me the next people in line for
second place would be the Colt 45 s
slash Houston Astros that started in
1962 in 1962 the Chicago Cubs were
already fifty-four years into their
route okay 1962 is 54 years from where
the [ __ ] we are right now right so the
Astros are 54 years under their drought
where the Cubs were in 1962 and the Cubs
are now twice that at 108 I don't know
what the [ __ ] that means does that mean
that you should go play the lottery
right now 54 62 1 0 8 I have no idea
what that [ __ ] means it's just you
know one of those one of those number
things but I gotta tell you it's almost
fitting that if the Cubs were gonna win
it that they would torture their [ __ ]
fans to this level and it's fitting that
if the Indians were gonna lose it they
would go up 3 2 1 to lift their [ __ ]
team's hopes this is why I think the
Cubs are gonna win if Terry Francona
wasn't in that dugout the master by the
way he needs that guy needs a nickname
like the assassin he needs like a boxer
nickname like remember lights out James
Toney you know well the executioner
Bernard Hopkins he needs a name like
that it's just that he doesn't look like
that but that's exactly what that guy is
all right what I'm saying is because of
what these teams have done to their fans
it would be fitting that the [ __ ]
Cubs wouldn't just go in and win the
[ __ ] thing so their fans could just
relax and finally enjoy a series they
would have to go down 3 2 1 before they
come back and then Cleveland couldn't
just lose the series they'd have to go
up three games to one so this is what's
crazy about three gear up three games to
one you like holy [ __ ] you're starting
to take the wire off the champagne
bottle at that point right but then all
of a sudden you [ __ ] lose Game five
and just instantly it's like holy [ __ ]
if we lose the next one it's all tied up
so now the pressure is on the Indians
I'll tell you the Cubs are going in
there that playing loose
nothing to lose other than [ __ ] a 108
year drought I don't know who's on the
mound I don't know what but I'm gonna
say the obvious the Cubs got to go
they've got to got a score early and
make the [ __ ] Indians tighten up
that's what the [ __ ] they got to do or
that's what's gonna happen in Game six
either the Cubs are gonna score early
Indians [ __ ] tighten up and then lose
the game and then we get a Game seven
or if the Indians go up early it's gonna
be a bloodbath it's gonna be a [ __ ] show
I'm hoping the first thing happens
because I want to see I want to see a
Game seven against a team that hasn't
won in 108 years in a team that hasn't
won it and [ __ ] uh what is it 68
[ __ ] years
68 is adorable to a Red Sox fan that's
[ __ ] hilarious I'm happy with [ __ ]
that's like--that's weather we were
there in like the 70s right it was 68
for us I was at the Mets
let's see 1918 to 1978
that's 60 years right and six I was 1986
so you just did Bill Buckner go [ __ ]
yourselves you know you just did Bill
Buckner as far as where I'm coming from
you got to go another [ __ ] another
eighteen years to 2004 so I guess I
won't root for the Indians now I can't I
[ __ ] I don't know my relatives got me
into the Indians I don't know what to do
I don't know a little route for here you
know I'm rooting for him rooting for a
game seven room for a game seven and
then they're gonna go up against each
other and one team's finally gonna win
that critical Game seven and get the
monkey off their back and then another
one is just gonna add another giant
cinderblock right on the [ __ ] hearts
of their fans it's kind of all God
this one has trained right we're written
all over it all right let me read a
little bit of [ __ ] our advertising
odd Jesus there bill you didn't [ __ ]
copy and paste them
I don't by the way you guys are watching
a series because it's it's been
unbelievable what a [ __ ]
right series it's bad Christ what am i
doing come on bill click here click
there all right how many do we got here
all right okay here we go
Oh Luke rate everybody give me the loop
are you looking for gear collectibles
housewares and more and more from your
favorite pop culture franchise we've got
you covered this is how like hipsters
and I guess nerds get laid you know this
is all about loot crate should be like
nerd crate you know just be like a
pocket [ __ ] in there or something we've
got you covered loo crate offers a range
of geek and gamer items for less than
$20 a month
gamers are weird berry that total nerds
or they're like [ __ ] jocks have you
noticed that like video games kind of
transcend like the whole was that
Matthew brought up movie wargames sort
of thing you know we got the underwear
on top of your head and you're like
trying to make a woman through your
computer rather than just [ __ ]
getting a hooker like a normal kid who
plays sports with hand-eye coordination
you just you know cuz what is his nerd
still not a flag down a hooker like
Gordon athlete you know sends the signal
to his athletic hand you know and just
brings him in all right you want to
bring your loot to the next level get a
bigger box with even bigger loop with
loot crate DX if you're more than the
Thai would love to see the sizes of
these [ __ ] t-shirts what do they
start at I just picture everybody goes
to comic-con looks like a young bird for
lanch Bruce Vilanch she was that [ __ ]
guy with the red glasses who thinks he's
[ __ ] hilarious and writes all the
speeches for people he's really the
craft of writing jokes and he has those
Sally Jessy Raphael glasses if you're
more than the type to wear your geeky he
looks like a like you know where the
wild things are like the way he has his
hair and [ __ ] if you're more than the
type to wear your geeky heart on your
sleeve then Lou we're sorry our monthly
wearables an accessory subscription is
the Droid you're looking for
that chill running up your spine isn't
your imagination its loot crate's
October theme horror we're taking over
40 years of creepy can't be bloody icons
and putting them in this month's loot
crate channel your best final girl with
items from The Walking Dead Nightmare on
Elm Street Friday the 13th Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and Halloween
what's final girl I'm gonna look that up
you have until the 19th at 9 p.m.
Pacific to subscribe well it's the
[ __ ] 31st the 19th of what that
months crate and when the cutoff happens
then it's over make sure to head over to
WWE my enter the code bird to save three
dollars off any new subscription today
just go to the website I don't know what
the [ __ ] they were offering now I'm sure
there's some sort of horror movie that
had a turkey in it right so that'll take
you into November oh yeah what's his
face what's his face there dude
Reservoir Dogs Quentin Tarantino he did
that movie here thanks for giving her
that alright Dollar Shave Club everybody
guys you know to go to Dollar Shave Club
for a fantastic shave there what you
probably don't know is that they have
other amazing products too
the quality is the best on the market
their body wash is great and won't dry
out your skin their pre shave and
post-shave stuff keeps your skin soft
and smooth there's stuff Wilkie I have
you looking and smelling like a million
bucks
well it must have just came from the
mint man because money's pretty filthy
right you don't to put that anywhere
near you
Dollar Shave Club got stuff for your
hair for your face for your under parts
for everywhere you want to keep you in
to keep you feeling and looking fresh
once you're in the club you'll see they
got the best grooming products out there
and they're affordable right now your is
right now is your chance to see for
yourself why so many people love jolly
shave club if you're not a member
yet and I've never joined now's the time
you'll get your first month of raises
for free just pay shipping and that's
only a few bucks joined today go to
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's actually
great [ __ ] you know what I mean you look
it smelled great when you go on a date
you don't I mean that's good for the
ladies you know maybe they'll be a
little less upset when you're going to
make your move that night alright what
do I want to talk about now let's go
let's go - I went down to UM
I went down to LA go last night been
slogging through my new [ __ ] [ __ ]
trying to see where the the new hours
going to come from and I don't know
we'll see we'll see all I know is I
don't have any [ __ ] rope gigs til
February so I can just totally chill out
I've been working out and eating like a
[ __ ] animal though you know I made
this pumpkin bread and [ __ ] you know
Rogan gave me some of that delt burger I
made it late last night and then a slice
of pumpkin bread after it so it's weird
it's like I'm in really good shape but I
also got this belly but I don't know
like I love the [ __ ] holidays and to
me the holidays is you throw down and
you cook you make stuff for your friends
you know I mean [ __ ] that I'm not
getting a [ __ ] bottle of champagne
you know what I'm gonna finish this
[ __ ] podcast and I'm gonna go make
some goddamn pumpkin bread
alright I'll show my wife I'll show her
who's boss by the way you guys really
enjoyed that to our podcast huh I think
we just went into a zone to our podcast
is a long-ass [ __ ] time unless you
hang in with Joe Rogan who I hung out
with and finally got him on the podcast
last Thursday if you missed it and once
again he has a new amazing stand-up
special called triggered we talked about
everything from hunting elk and wild
[ __ ] boar to working out UFC [ __ ]
election stuff stand-up comedy just had
a great [ __ ] time about his special
is on Netflix so definitely check it out
if you get a chance
and all right let's get back to let's
get back to the the podcast here o f1
action in f1 action I totally missed the
[ __ ] race but I read up on it Lewis
Hamilton wins again for those you sort
of keeping score now that I've been
keeping score you get 25 points if you
win 18 for second 15th or third then
it's 12 10 8 6 4 2 1 right that's the
top pilot top [ __ ] 10 works Cleo you
could not be more adorable right now
what it is is she wants F ood I got up a
little bit early to do this podcast so
now she's come over she sat down next to
me her ears are down and she's rested
her head on my arm and she's just
staring at me like I don't know what's
going on alright dude I've got another
20 minutes just [ __ ] relax no no no
no not coming up on the couch going cold
lay down go lay down go lay down
Cleo get out of here please Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] I get it get out of here
Cleo get off of the couch lay down now
she's needy alright anyways so
Rosberg had a [ __ ] league and the
last two [ __ ] races Hamilton has won
both so he's shaved 14 [ __ ] points
off of the lead all [ __ ] Nico had to
do was [ __ ] win one more race I felt
if he could have won it yesterday
he could have wrapped this thing up I'm
kind of glad that he didn't because I
want to see the person [ __ ] wrap it
up so the next race I believe is in
Brazil which is not until November 13th
and I apologized to f1 fans because I
know I got into this [ __ ] and then I
just dropped the ball in like the last
four or five ones but I'm [ __ ] living
in this goddamn house I [ __ ] up I
forgot that it that it was this week and
that I actually figured out through
Apple TV or some [ __ ] that I patiently
worked my way through and actually
figured out that I could actually get
was at NBC Sports is that the name of
the channel and I could have watched the
game
we could watch the race so I got to go
home today my house around the [ __ ]
corner take that [ __ ] thing by the
way the kitchen's just come to a
grinding [ __ ] halt I don't know why
but they still tell us that they're
gonna finish on [ __ ] time so whatever
whatever I'm sure they will [ __ ] sure
they will all right let's get out of
this let's let's do some talk about not
you guys watched Clemson Florida [ __ ]
amazing game I also watched the not
Clemson Florida Florida State that I
also watched Florida [ __ ] Georgia you
know I was thinking when I first saw it
I was just like man I got to go to that
game I gotta go to that game in
Jacksonville the biggest outdoor
cocktail party in the world as they say
and I'm like I bet the fans are cool
with each other they're [ __ ] you know
cuz it's a neutral site you know
everybody's just psyched to be away from
their house sorry I'm [ __ ] yawning
here
Georgia scores first they cut to the
Georgia fans in the stands and I clearly
see this guy turned around not facing
the field and just giving the finger to
the Florida fans above them and I'm just
like wow alright it's at that level okay
it's at that [ __ ] level I die you
know I really had no interest in going
to that game I'd want to go to the swamp
and I've been to what Georgia home game
between the hedges and I've been doing
Jacksonville verse Bengals games so I
felt like I've been to that Stadium but
after seeing it was like [ __ ] man that
looks like fun and I always have a great
time in Jacksonville everybody shits on
Jacksonville it's a good [ __ ] time if
you take the stick out of your ass you
can go to a gun range shoot guns with
the without with the [ __ ] silencer on
all right clear the only thing I gonna
do is just sit here and pet you as I do
the rest of this alright alright
Westwood dear bill glad you love
Westworld
for some reason he wrote Westwood in the
beginning glad you love West world I
look forward to hearing your thoughts
and the rest of the season season if you
like that and you're looking for a great
movie to watch
check out the 13th floor it came out in
the late 90s and deals with similar
themes are you into reading fan theories
a common one now that is a non spoiler
is that Edie Harris's character
a nice guy who's new to the park are the
same person
another claims that it's actually all on
Mars
Oh for Westworld yeah well I got to get
caught up before people ruin [ __ ] I'll
definitely check out the 13th floor and
I think I'm gonna watch an episode
episode three of Westworld because I
think they're up to five at this point
I'm gonna watch that today and I'm gonna
get caught up and you know cuz my wife
[ __ ] cheated on me want with TV you
know what I mean when you guys have your
shows right we watch that show below
deck with the yachties get on there
right and it's just it's a reality show
that we could both watch because they're
always in the [ __ ] Mediterranean they
got a [ __ ] yacht it's the [ __ ] we
always said ah we should do that it'd be
[ __ ] awesome and then you look up the
prices and it's like the price of a
house to rent one of those [ __ ]
things you got to be like Beyonce and
jay-z like both of you can sell out the
Rose Bowl on any given [ __ ] night you
know you got to be that level of wealth
to [ __ ] justify do you realize the
two of them almost worth a billion
dollars
so for them to blow 250 grand on a
[ __ ] yacht is like let's say you're
worth a hundred million dollars if
you're worth a hundred million dollars
two hundred fifty grand is like point
two five percent of your money right cuz
a million is like 1% right so I don't
know how to work that out it's like 25
percent of 1% whatever the [ __ ] that is
of your money and they're worth ten
times that so that that's like you and I
hey you want to out for a week and you
take a penny out of your pocket and you
break it into four [ __ ] pieces and
just hand it to them there you go there
you go yeah we'd like all the amenities
anyways I will definitely be be checking
that out
Edie Harris is like as always as always
one of the greatest actress of all
[ __ ] time
I'll watch anything that that guy sent I
swear to god the only thing I never saw
is when he was the one where uh
[ __ ] the only one I I never saw was the
one when he played the painter and that
got nominated or he got nominated for an
Oscar so I still haven't seen that once
I gotta check that out all right
old toys dear Billy Potato Head I love
that that's a good one cuz that kind of
shits on my Irish heritage and then also
makes fun of the shape of my head if if
if you ever have kids will you try and
expose them to toys that you enjoyed as
a child you strike me as a matchbox car
kid I don't force the toys of my
childhood on my kids but I've put a
couple army men in there general area to
give them a chance to play like I did I
am a huge agree of that proponent of
that opponent of that proponent oh
that's what proponent means you're pro
right I never knew what that meant I
just kind of figured that out opponent
proponent Oh pumpkin bread pro pumpkin
bread I get it
yeah absolutely I absolutely I
absolutely will do that my big thing is
playing catch and you know I'm gonna buy
a [ __ ] I'm gonna buy a leftie glove
for myself is what I'm gonna do because
I can throw a little bit with my left
hand and rather than just sitting there
firing it into my kid I'd [ __ ] I'm
gonna I'm gonna go with the left hand we
were doing that yesterday we had a
football right his play set up we're
renting here has this [ __ ] great pool
so it was halftime of the Florida game
and we're out there smoking cigars and
[ __ ] and we finished that up we got the
game turned up loud so the game became
there was four guys right so you had two
on one side of the pool two on the other
side of the pool so you had to throw
with your opposite hand first person
that's sent it into the pool or if you
had a catchable ball and it fell into
the pool was I don't know whatever the
[ __ ] it was it was was that thing that
word you can't [ __ ] say anymore cuz
everybody gets offended and it's not a
racial slur but it is you know you know
you know the word
nobody said it but we all know we you
know without saying yeah we're older
guys like that's what it means so
anyways yeah I would definitely do that
was I was not a matchbox car kid I was
Corgi cars we used to call him core G
cuz we didn't know it was pronounced
Corgi till we got older and I'm so old
that I remember when they had rubber
wheels on him and I had the giant oil
truck I was big I had all the race cars
I had the Johnny players special I had
the Jackie Stewart elf car and my mother
doesn't throw out [ __ ] so I still have
all of them I had one of those you know
that that kind of racing where the car
just looks like a giant doorstop it
wasn't Formula One it wasn't in it's not
IndyCar racing it's not open wheel you
don't the car looks like a waterslide
like you could you could slide from the
fin all the way down to the front I
don't know what kind of a white and red
one of those Lincoln Logs Lego Lego
blocks you know stuff like that I think
it's big to not have you to keep you
kids you know I don't know you gotta get
them outside and you got it you got to
keep them in their own like I don't know
I have such a great rate of computers
and iPads and all of that [ __ ]
and kids just love them I mean they go
up to it like you know liquid television
type of [ __ ] you know back in the day
the MTV I remember that graphic I used
to just make me want to sit down and
watch it I don't know mr. Potato Head I
don't know about that definitely like
board games I think it'd be fun playing
cards
I think it's cool to expose your kids to
that you know so they have like that
old-school [ __ ]
like wasn't it always the greatest like
when like for me if I met some woman I
took her out on a date and she had she
had some old school stuff about her you
know I mean that that stuff that was
sort of passed down I think that's
really like a cool thing and I think
like some [ __ ] like playing cards
playing catch
like going outside it's just like you
know riding bicycles just like all that
[ __ ] is going away and I'm not one of
these old people that I look at young
kids in injury like you know what are
they doing today they're [ __ ] nuts
and these kids today they don't get it
and it's just like I totally get why
they're doing it because I had to tap
out Grand Theft Auto 3 in like 2003 or
2004 I had to unplug my PlayStation and
stick it in the back of the closet
I literally just one day it was like the
fifth day in a row I was just playing
all day long and I could not stop
I'd already beat the game I got the
cheats I did all of that [ __ ] and then I
was just going on rampages every night
just shooting up the city and I just you
know I kind of just lost everything else
in my life I wasn't writing jokes and
all that [ __ ] so that was like 13 years
ago so I can't imagine how amazing the
games are and like the virtual reality
goggles and all of that [ __ ] I can't
even [ __ ] imagine like how you get
your kid to go in the backyard and just
have a game and catch back to me that's
the greatest [ __ ] thing ever I think
it's a great way to communicate with
your kid you know I mean because you
it's like you do that's another activity
going on so they're not really paying
attention you can praise them when
they're doing well you know build up
their confidence and then you just slide
in so I was it going at school you know
and then you just read them fat's go
great alright so it's going good of you
it seemed kind of look down you know
that's alright what's the matter what's
going on they can kind of open up to you
I think it's like a great way to I think
it's really important early on to be
able to do that to have your kid be able
to come to you if they have a [ __ ]
problem is a is a huge thing but how you
sit there with a glove and a ball and
how that competes with putting on
[ __ ] reality glasses and you feel
like you're gonna [ __ ]
base jump off of a building or whatever
the [ __ ] they do I don't know what the
[ __ ] they do with those things yeah
that's a that's that's a difficult
that's a difficult one
I love Lincoln Logs I lie I didn't like
Lego blocks she stepped on when your
bare feet they [ __ ] hurt not the
Lincoln Logs did but like that plastic
[ __ ] I wasn't into that as much as uh
the Lincoln Logs are cool we used to
[ __ ] build those things we build
houses and then we would you know with
their core geek orgy car Corgi cars
whatever [ __ ] they called drive them
around we'd have traffic jams and all of
that type of [ __ ] we had names for
everybody that drove the cars remember I
had all the [ __ ] race cars in in all
my it's weird they drove like a Formula
One car to work and then they drove the
trucks
I had trucks in racing cars then my
other brother was a total [ __ ]
gearhead he actually liked like the real
looking cars like a Volkswagen bug or
like a station wagon like he wanted to
look like the cars that you could
actually [ __ ] drive oh I know my
mother didn't throw all of those out
Jesus Christ it's [ __ ] nuts they're
all up in the attic somewhere
all right election bill the election is
right around the corner a couple weeks
ago you eulogize the Great Barrier Reef
any last words for this election not the
country as a whole because I don't think
it'll fall apart by and imagine this has
exposed the side of our country that
we've been able to keep under wraps for
a while which is that no one ever pays
attention to anything unless it's an
easy talking point not everything is
more [ __ ] up than we know or would
like to admit what's the worst thing
that will happen if either candidate
wins
well if Trump wins the worst thing is
we're gonna have to listen to all these
European countries talk about how dumb
Americans are especially people in
England and I just want to say to them
like you know what what if you threw out
the person every four to eight years and
I would love to see what the [ __ ] you
end up with you know what I mean some
years it's just not a good draft it
[ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] his name is Tony Blair
that guy's been in this since bush not
even saying that guy's good but you just
get somebody in there and they just stay
there until they die
doesn't he have like Margaret Thatcher's
job Oh
the original Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton can't even say her [ __ ] name
Wow what's the worst that will happen I
don't know if Trump wasn't such a
[ __ ] jerk-off he wasn't such a
jerk-off it's really what the country
needs you need somebody who isn't a part
of the [ __ ] system you don't but you
just can't have a guy like that in there
and then Hillary is just gonna be more
of the [ __ ] same it's just gonna keep
driving this country towards ruined dude
none of them talked about the population
problem none of them talked about the
nationwide heroin epidemic
none of them talked about genetically
altered food none of them talked about
[ __ ] global warming maybe they
touched on it for a second they haven't
said [ __ ] they're not gonna do anything
none of I'm gonna try to stop the banks
put them in [ __ ] line to build in
another real estate bubble I'll tell you
what's [ __ ] hilarious out here is
they are building up la like I've never
[ __ ] seen they brought up the House
of Blues right across the street from
the [ __ ] from the [ __ ] a comedy
store they play like twenty eight
million dollars for the thing they're
gonna put these these high-rise [ __ ]
million dump multi-million dollar
[ __ ] condos in there it's like who
the [ __ ] gonna Ford to buy those
things all right and this is the thing
after 2008 after we saw what happened
they [ __ ] gave the house none of the
bankers went to jail they gave them the
houses back so they could do it all over
again they're building another [ __ ]
bubble and I'm already calling it right
now by [ __ ] 2021 2022 or some [ __ ]
there is going to be a bunch of empty
[ __ ] condo [ __ ] high-rises going
along the Sunset Strip and they have
knocked down the Rainbow Room the Roxy
the wicks whiskey House of Blues
maybe the Comedy Store they're gonna
wipe out all of these [ __ ] things
there's gonna be nobody in those
buildings and even if they are in those
buildings they're gonna have no [ __ ]
place to go because they knock down all
the cool places to hang out on Sunset
Strip it's so [ __ ] stupid you know
I was getting gassed the other day
another place on the Sunset Strip and
this guy said I say hey you own the gas
station he goes I wish I did
this property just sold for 14 million
bucks and you know they're knocking down
the two buildings next to it and they're
gonna put up a [ __ ] you know 170 unit
[ __ ] I don't know I just don't know
where all these people are gonna be
coming that can afford to pay I just
don't know where they're gonna come from
and for what I heard you know at least
the ones on La Cienega that was like oil
money you know like Saudi Arabian money
came in and they they don't give a [ __ ]
I mean they got money forever I don't
know what's the worst thing will happen
if he the candidate comes in is that
they're not going to stop what's already
going on and I got to be honest with you
I don't even think like you know all the
Bernie Sanders and all those types of
people you would literally need an army
of those people and then they would need
bulletproof vests to [ __ ] just that's
how powerful corporations are and that's
how off the [ __ ] rails we are I don't
know which is why I'm trying to focus on
the propositions and I wish if anybody
can find a [ __ ] website out there
that not only lets me know what i'm
voting for but lets me know what is
attached to it like because who doesn't
want to improve the schools you know but
you know whenever they have stuff like
that like hey let's clean up the
drinking water then they attach all this
other evil [ __ ] underneath it I don't
know I don't know it's it's all very
overwhelming so it's so [ __ ]
overwhelming that you're asking extend
up comedian what's going to happen or
maybe you just did because you want to
hear me make a [ __ ] ass of myself all
right here we go cool guy terrible in
bed no Jesus all right dear Billy Bush
beer I'm a twenty year old female
college student I go to Holy Cross Oh
in all he said is I go to Holy Cross
okay I go to Holy Cross in Worcester
I had a boyfriend for the first three
years of college and now I'm single I
hooked up with a guy that I didn't know
was kind of an [ __ ]
he's sort of popular and seemed friendly
one drunken night I did the worst thing
I could do fed his ego
had I known he was a [ __ ] in a pompous
douche bag I would not have done this
I'll save you the reasons why he's a
douche bag but just picture lame
eighties preppy bully who thinks he's
God's gift again I didn't know this
because I'd never paid attention to him
well after we hooked up he told some
people that I told him he was the best
[ __ ] I ever had this found its way back
to me and Bill I was shocked
why because he was the worst [ __ ] I ever
had he had no idea what he was doing he
was for lack of better words not present
no rhythm an average at best I wasn't
mad at this because it was my choice to
hook up with him but now he's putting
words in my mouth I really just want to
tell someone how bad he was and wait for
it to get back around to him what is my
move here bill and/or Nia wait a minute
did you say he was late one drunk at
night I did the worst thing I could do
feed his stupid ego does that mean that
you slept with him I can't tell if you
buy feed his ego you you he was so bad
you felt like you had to say something
nice now there's no [ __ ] way you said
there's no way you said he was the best
[ __ ] I think you're saying yeah yeah I
think you're saying that you fed his ego
by hooking up with them
had I known he was a [ __ ] or pompous -
okay so he's walking around saying that
you said and you also say he's putting
words in your mouth so I'm assuming that
you never said that so fed his ego means
that you [ __ ] hooked up with them
that's what I'm guessing I don't [ __ ]
know
I wasn't mad at too
because um well oh this is tough one I
would I would call him up then when he
picked up I'd be like why are you
walking around saying that I said you
were the best [ __ ] I ever had I never
said that okay I never said that okay
and hear what he says and you know
something there might be a thinks is the
thing this [ __ ] a lot of these guys like
this a tremendously insecure maybe he
knows he doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing so he's walking around saying that
so he can feel better about himself
because he feels that awful about
himself and he feels so [ __ ] awful
about himself that not only does he
gotta go that big that the the [ __ ]
way he feels about himself he's such a
big thing that it doesn't he doesn't
even think that that's gonna get back to
you or he doesn't even consider your
[ __ ] feelings so you can either be
the biggest person and know that this
person is tremendously insecure and
walks around and probably doesn't like
themselves which is a [ __ ] horrible
feeling to have and just take peace with
that or you can call a guy out which I
kind of like okay and I you know and at
that point you gonna be listen if you
were the best [ __ ] I ever had I would
have said that to you and just leave it
at that because you haven't sold him it
he's completely [ __ ] inept you know
what I mean
but you're also kind of putting the guy
in check then then you have your final
option which is you can go around saying
that he wasn't the best [ __ ] I ever had
he's [ __ ] terrible it Benny what
happens is everybody just gets to sit
back and enjoy watching you guys [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] I understand why you'd want
to do it I don't know I don't do the
revenge thing I kind of go to the person
that's
doing whatever they're doing that's
[ __ ] annoying me and I just kind of
chopped the head off there and and then
if somebody comes up to me and says what
they said I would say I would just say
impersonally yeah that isn't true I
never said that I don't know I don't
know what the [ __ ] to do I I'm sorry
that this happened to you
and at 20 years of age it's probably
hard to understand a lot of the [ __ ]
that I'm saying that of what that guy
feels about himself but you know you
can't have somebody walking around
saying [ __ ] like that about you so I I
would first thing I'll do I was confront
the guy call him up and be like why are
you saying that I never said that you
know and if you continue to say that and
if he kind of goes around to the loo if
you continue to say that you're leaving
me in a position here that I have to
tell them the truth okay you're not the
best [ __ ] I ever had
all right I don't know it's just I don't
know that's that's a do you know guys if
you listen to this thing and you're a
young person that's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing to do all right
that's totally coming from your own
goddamn insecurity all right and as an
older wiser [ __ ] man you know I wish
that somebody older told me that when
you hook up with somebody you keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut you know what I mean
you're quiet about it you know it
happened who gives a [ __ ] who knows you
don't I mean that's it's an insecure
[ __ ] move and just sit there and then
she did this and then did dad she
[ __ ] did this like that's a really
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing to do and in women
if you hook up with the guy and he's
[ __ ] terrible or he's got a little
dick and all that type of [ __ ] right if
he's not out there talking [ __ ] for you
to walk around [ __ ] doing that -
that's another [ __ ] [ __ ] move it's
an [ __ ] move either way and in this
case the guy's the [ __ ] so I don't
know you know something if you can hang
on until Thursday I'll run it by Nia
I'll have her on again and I'll run it
by
just that she's still sleeping here so
anyways alright let me go that's it for
the questions let me read the last two
advertisements here and then I got some
pumpkin bread to make alright SeatGeek
buying tickets online for sports and
concerts has been a confusing process
for a long time it's always been hard to
find the best deal for that game or show
you want to go to and none of those
older ticket sites want to change that
but it's SeatGeek it's different they've
come along and created an amazing app
and website that makes it easier than
ever for fans to buy and sell tickets
eek-eek does all the price comparisons
for you by searching multiple ticket
sites and ensuring that you get the best
possible deal and see geek wants to help
you get the most bang for your buck
that's why every ticket NC geek is given
a grade based on value you'll
immediately see why any under priced
seats you mainly see any under priced
seats and be able to find the best deals
fit for your budget best of all my
listeners get a $20 off rebate their
first seat geek purchase to get $20 to
get your $20 rebate on tickets download
the sea geek app go to the settings tab
and click add a promo code enter promo
code per seat will send you $20 and
after you've made your first ticket
purchase o after you've made your first
ticket purchase download the sea geek
app and enter the promo code birt'day
alright and stamps calm now ur old
friends here some small businesses still
thinking think an expensive postage beta
is the only way to get postage without
having to go to the post office but they
are wrong wrong wrong
there's stamps calm Oh with stamps.com
you can easily print postage for any
letter or package using just your
computer and printer no extra hardware
to buy no long term contract stamps comm
can save you at least 50% compared to a
meter plus you can do more with stamps
come then then you can with the meter
like send package tracking information
and recipients with one-click the choice
is clear stance comm offers more
features at a fraction of the costs I've
been using stamps Capcom for years from
my show for my posters actually it makes
mailing and shipping really convene
right now signup for stamps com use my
last name Barbie you are our to get a
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes postage and a digital
scale scale don't wait go to Stan's calm
before you do anything else click on the
microphone to top the homepage and type
in / be you are are all right that is it
that is the podcast
let's go cubbies I want to see it game
seven and then listen I don't want to
see either one of you guys lose you know
what I mean you've both waited long
enough
but I got a root for the Cubs in Game
six because I want to see a Game seven
alright that's it I got my app the NHL
app is working for me now I'll be
watching Bruins games and that type of
[ __ ] and I'm gonna try to watch that
Formula One race for all you [ __ ]
gearheads out there alright go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check on Thursday